>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Carlos Olave: Good afternoon.
My name is Carlos Olave.
I am the head of the
Hispanic Reading Room.
And I'd like to welcome you
to today's cultural program.
So, [cough] excuse me.
The Hispanic Division
was founded in 1939
and was the first international
reading room
in [inaudible] studies established
by the Library of Congress.
In that same year the Hispanic
Reading Room was inaugurated
to service the library.
Library is growing
Luso-Hispanic Collections.
The Reading Room is center for the
Hispanic Studies and offers services
in English, Spanish and Portuguese.
About 250 researchers visit the
Hispanic Reading Room each month
to research Hispanic
materials of all kinds.
Although its primary emphasis
has always been the acquisition
of current materials and government
documents, the Hispanic division,
has also acquired a rich
collection of rare items.
The division has been instrumental
in acquiring significant gifts,
manuscripts, music [inaudible],
posters, photographs and films.
It has developed special
groups of materials
such as collecting folk music
from San Antonio, Texas,
and partnering [phonetic] the
recording of Hispanic writers,
through its archive of
Hispanic literature on tape
which is currently and
gradually been digitized
for wider public access.
The Library of Congress houses
13.5 million items relating
to the Luso-Hispanic world.
Of these 13.5 million items, 3.2
million are books and serials.
The staff of the Hispanic Reading
Room overseas the materials,
they assist the researchers,
[inaudible] items such as maps,
recordings, manuscripts,
prints, photographs,
reference books, and artifacts.
The Library of Congress has massed
the world's finest collection
on the history and culture of Latin
America, Iberia, the Caribbean,
and that of the Hispanic
population in the United States.
Many of the rare items were received
as gifts, such as rare books,
donated by Lessing J.
Rosenwald, and manuscripts given
by Hans Crouse [phonetic].
[Inaudible] have enabled
the Hispanic division
to purchase materials
in various formats,
in addition to books
and prearticles.
And now, I will introduce to
you Catalina Gómez, my college,
who will introduce our guest.
Thank you.
>> Catalina Gomez: Thank
you all for being here.
I'm Catalina Gómez, reference
librarian in the Hispanic division,
and is my great pleasure
to introduce today's poet.
María Augusta Montealegre is a poet
and literally critic from Nicaragua.
She's the author of
two books of poems,
"El País de las Calles Sin Nombre"
which was published in 2014,
published also in English,
under the title
"Where the Streets Have No Name",
and this was a very recent
publication in 2017, this year.
And another book of poems, "La
Oración que Efraín Nos Enseñó"
which was publish in 2015.
She's also the author of a book
of Nicaraguan 20th century poetry
titled -- poetry and history titled,
"Ideas estéticas y políticas de
las vanguardias en Nicaragua,
volumen uno, Salomón de Selva".
Sharing her BA in international
relations from the Univeristy
of Las Américas, from
Puebla, México,
and a PHD in avant-garde literature
from Spain and Latin America,
from the University
of Salamanca in Spain.
Most of her research has
focus on the political
and aesthetical avant-garde
ideas of Nicaragua.
Please join me in welcoming María.
[ Applause ]
>> María Augusta Montealegre:
Well, first of all I want
to thank very much for this
opportunity to read here
at the Library of Congress,
especially to the Hispanic
Reading Room.
Salomón de la Selva, 1893 -
1959, was a Nicaraguan immigrant
in the United States of America.
If we focus in the term "Latino
writer" as a 20th century phenomenon
of immigration, de
la Selva is the first
to write an English
anthology in the USA.
This positioned him as
the first Latin writer.
It is a pleasure for
me, to read his poetry.
Casa Tropical, the translation
is mine, from the book,
"Tropical Town and Other Poems".
Cuando llegue el invierno,
te voy a llevar a Nicaragua,
¡te va a encantar!
Te encantará mi hogar, mi casa en
Nicaragua, tan amplia y majestuosa,
con su aire altivo que parece
decirle a las montañas --
a las montañas de Nicaragua,
ya pueden rugir y temblar,
que no me importa.
Mi casa, es sombreada y fresca,
con un jardín en el centro,
donde árboles frutales crecen y
amapolas como un pequeño ejército,
hilera tras hilera, y arbustos de
jazmín que te recordarán la nieve,
son tan blancos y luminosos,
tan perfectos y frágiles
cuando el viento sopla,
se agitan, y así vuelan.
La bañera está en el jardín,
como una especie de piscina,
con muros de hiedra y
orquídeas en derredor.
Siempre el colibrí haciendo
un sonido que invita al sueño,
en las noches aparece
un ruiseñor azteca.
Más cuando sale la
luna, en Nicaragua,
la luna de Nicaragua y
sus millones de estrellas,
el corazón del hombree
es el que canta,
y canta el corazón de Nicaragua,
a la súplica un desolado
lamento de guitarras.
The version of Salomón de la Selva
was in English, "Tropical House".
When the winter comes,
I will take you
to Nicaragua, you will
love it there.
You will love my home,
my house in Nicaragua.
So large and queenly
looking with a haughty air,
that seems to tell the mountains
-- the mountains of Nicaragua --
you may roar and you may
tremble, for all I care!
It is shadowy and cool.
Has a garden in the middle where
fruit-trees grow, and poppies,
like little army, row on row.
And jasmine bushes that
will make you think of snow.
They are so white, and light,
so perfect and so frail,
and when the wind is blowing,
they fly and flutter so!
The bath is in the garden,
like a sort of pool,
with walls of honeysuckle
and orchids all around.
The hummingbird is always
making a sleeping sound.
In the night there's
the Aztec nightingale.
But when the moon is up, in
Nicaragua, the moon of Nicaragua
and the million stars, it's
the human heart that sings,
and the heart of Nicaragua, to the
pleading plaintive music of guitars.
Despite "Tropical Town and Other
Poems" used to be modernista,
recent studies show that the
aesthetic of the book can be read
as avant-garde because of
the intellectual achievement
of co-experience -
That focus on the modern phenomenon
of immigration and because
of his protests in an
already a modern world.
My translation is "Una
canción para Wall Street".
En Nicaragua, mi Nicaragua, ¿qué
puedes comprar con un penny?
Una canasta llena de albaricoques,
una jarra de barro
llena con agua fresca,
un rosario con cuentas de coral
y la plegaria de un sacerdote.
Y por dos pennies --
por dos pennies, la música
más extraña jamás escuchada,
salida de la garganta de un
pajarillo, un pájaro de barro,
y para ser generoso, te daremos,
la palabra de un patriota.
Y por un níquel, un
blanco y brillante níquel,
su tierra un hombre puede comprar
una mina de oro larga y profunda,
un bosque que creciendo alto,
una pequeña casa con techo rojo,
y el río que pasa su orilla.
Más por un dólar -- tu socio
dólar, tu leproso verde,
es solo odio lo que puedes conseguir
de todo mi pueblo y de mí, por ello,
deja tu dólar donde
pertenece y déjanos ser.
Su version, "A song
for Wall Street".
In Nicaragua, my Nicaragua, what
can you buy for a penny there?
A basket full of apricots,
a water jug of earthenware,
a rosary of coral beads
and a priest's prayer.
And for two pennies?
For two pennies?
The strangest music ever heard,
all from the brittle little
throat of a clay bird.
And, for good measure, we will
give you a patriot's word.
And for a nickel?
A bright nickel?
It's lots of land a man can buy, a
golden mine that's long and deep,
a forest growing high,
and a little house
with a red roof, and
a river passing by.
But for your dollar, your dirty
dollar -- your greenish, leprosy,
it's only hatred you shall
get from all my folks and me.
So, keep your dollar where
it belongs, and let us be!
De La Selva continue the
legacy of Darío and Martín,
joining a movement
called, Pan-Americanism,
that opposed to the state
politic, proposing exchange
of culture instead of
exchange of goods and labor.
"Birds of Clay" is the only case
where De La Selva translated
himself, also,
he was a great translator,
from North American poetry
into Hispanic and vice versa.
Pajaritos de barro, traducción
de Salomón de la Selva.
Pajaritos de barro, pajaritos
del barro colorado de mi tierra,
que me pusisteis en el alma los
infinitos valores que encierra de
vuestro olor me acuerdo todavía,
un viejo olor de inmemorables
generaciones cuando mi voluntad
humedecía vuestros vacíos corazones,
con el vibrar fugitivo
de mi aliento,
¿para dónde volasteis
pajaritos de barro?
¿Con el ímpetu de qué vientos?
¿Al son de qué cantares?
¿Con el horror de qué gritos?
Cuando me muera quiero que se me
entierre donde arranquen los niños
sollozo y canción, avivando las
músicas esenciales que encierre el
pajarito de barro de mi corazón.
La version original,
"Birds of clay".
Birds of clay I whistle
through, have you flown away?
I remember the smell
of you, birds of clay!
Old it was!
So old, so old.
Dust of centuries of death,
all my childhood I was told,
you would fly, and are you fled?
When I am dead I want to lie
where in the centuries to be,
children shall utter song and cry
through the winged dust of me.
De La Selva was a cultural
translator, what he does is,
he negotiates from form by context,
he constructs the Nicaragua
imaginary in English aesthetic,
this is call "radical translation".
The best example is his
poem, Tropical Town --
Tropical Dance, when he uses
the [inaudible] a variation
of a formal English verse,
used from the 16th century.
My translation, "Canción
Folclórica Centroamericana".
¿Cómo te parieron Pelota?
¡Desnudo me han hecho, Pelota!
¡Al maíz vistieron, Pelota!
¡El maíz no es chanco, Pelota!
¡Ay Dios mío!, no
es chancho como yo.
¿Hacia dónde viajas, Pelota?
Muy lejos al sur, Pelota, ¡al
sur ni el sol viaja, Pelota!
Es que hay un albur, Pelota.
¡Ay Dios mío!, ni el
sol lo sabe, solo yo.
Tropical Dance.
How were you born, Pelota?
I was born nude, Pelota.
Not so the corn, Pelota.
The corn is not lewd, Pelota.
Not lewd as I, my God.
Where do you run, Pelota?
Far from the South, Pelota.
Not so the sun, Pelota.
There is a mouth, Pelota.
No sun knows but I, my God.
Salomón de la Selva,
was also a world poet.
He can be compared with
Season [phonetic] or Owen,
because De La Selva is the great
unknown poem of the first World War.
But he still followed Rubén Darío,
he remained faithful to Darío,
despite avant-garde poetry.
Darío was a synonym of
peace and happy time,
so the iconography he uses is
modernista, but the aesthetic
in which he writes, is avant-garde.
The bullet.
The translation is mine.
The bullet that will wound me,
will be a bullet with a soul.
The soul of that bullet will be
like a rose, if flowers could sing,
or like topaz if stone would have a
smell, or like the skin of a melody
if songs could be touched
naked with our hands.
If I am shot in the brain,
it will say, "I just wanted
to explore your thoughts".
And if it [inaudible] my chest,
I will say, "I just wanted
to tell you, I love you".
La bala. La bala que me
hiera será bala con alma.
El alma de esa bala será como
sería la canción de una rosa,
si las flores cantaran, o el olor de
un topacio si las piedras olieran,
o la piel de una música si nos
fuese posible tocar a las canciones
desnudas con las manos.
Si me hiere el cerebro, me dirá,
"yo buscaba sondear tu pensamiento",
y si me hiere el pecho, me dirá
"yo quería decirte que te quiero".
His book, "The Unknown Soldier", is
really a paper monument for those
who fought in the Great War.
But, during those very hard times
for immigrants in the United States.
This last poem that I'm going to
share with you, called "Testamento".
I also can read it as my
legacy of a Latin poem.
Form poet to poet, Testamento.
Testament, my translation.
To you, to all of you who
pure love gave with clear mind
and with deep emotion
and with great valor,
captain of my call [phonetic]
save this soul [inaudible] to fate
and if I privilege, shall return
my life to earth it came from,
I leave you my dead's glory.
And so, my Lord, advice with
heaven's consent, I want to die,
that once, my chivalry
[inaudible] tremblors.
My Spanish, my English,
Indian blood now.
And I have courage of centuries
tremble and of human races,
and of know how to be seen volcano,
rock and wave, and cloud for pride
and honor, grace and fate.
Now I'm going to share with
you, a reading of my own poetry,
from a book called "El País
de las Calles sin Nombre"
"Where the Streets Have No Name".
I'm going to do a little bit
of [inaudible] traduction.
There is a YouTube song title as my
book, but the idea of this working
to me, when Hillary Clinton
visited my country and declared
that she was amazed by the fact
that our streets have no names.
I remember when I was little, my mom
told me it was not always like that.
And my [inaudible] town, used
to be an urban city before an
earthquake shuttered my country more
than four decades ago.
After that, we devised a
new way of locating things.
We started using trees as landmarks.
In addition, we use movable
references and stones to get around.
Somehow, my children
understood how to use this system
by giving me directions to their
school in the United States.
Using landmarks such as
yellow car and a big oak tree.
I ask them -- how do
I know when to turn
if one day the yellow
car is no longer there?
-- They laughed and gave
me a Nicaraguan answer --
mom, the yellow car
will always be there --
Since I come from a different
culture, here are some hints
to find your way around my country.
Even though the metric system is
our primary way of measurement,
we always refer back to an ancient
Spanish measurement called "vara".
We call the west, down, the east,
up, when we say to the lake,
we mean to the north, but
when we say to the south,
it actually means to the south.
If the yellow car is no
longer there, than we assume
that everyone will know
that location by memory,
by referencing the
location retroactively
as where the yellow car was.
Of course, as a foreigner,
you will have to ask locals
where those landmarks are,
because those landmarks
come from an oral tradition.
If you use this knowledge you
will know your way around.
To name our street is
too expensive, and yes,
[inaudible] reach its destination.
It is important to say that
with this translation I intend
to honor those people who cannot
speak English and still write
about their place of origin without
being read in the United States.
Welcome to Managua, where 2.5
million people manage to survive,
work, play, love, laugh
and find their way around,
in a city where the
streets have no names.
At the obelisk, first round about.
This is a poem that is
inspired by, "Birds of Clay",
from Salomón de la Selva.
It's call "The Arch".
A mouth that thrills.
A mouth that hoods.
A mouth that whistles.
That [inaudible].
That pip [phonetic].
That crocs.
That screams.
That squeezes.
That bleeds.
That [inaudible].
That sings.
That hunks.
That shirks [phonetic].
That coughs.
That trumpets.
That [inaudible].
That clocks.
That blossoms.
That puffs.
That pillows.
That [inaudible].
That whinnies [phonetic].
That nights.
That snores.
That roars.
That barks.
That house.
That wine.
That [inaudible].
That meals.
That wales [phonetic].
That [inaudible] that whispers, that
mutters [phonetic], that purses,
a mouth that speaks,
a mouth that anchors,
a mouth that chirps [phonetic].
If you give me a kiss, I
can stood the whole world
in the arch of your mouth.
Next poem is a little bit far away
from the Salomonic inspirations,
is more of my own voice.
Its name is Boa Constrictor.
I sway from side to
side like a pendulum,
like the ticking of a clock.
If you don't suspect
anything, you look at me
as [inaudible] you sniff
the air like a Bengal tiger,
preparing to strike, you wait for
me to leave my skin in some corner.
I am your prey.
I use my body as a bait,
sinking my mortal [hiss].
I move forward with new skin.
I flick my playful tongue.
I hypnotize you with my
eyes to keep you still.
I dart towards you.
I call myself around your body.
You roar furiously, you resist,
and suffocated by my embrace,
you listen to the breaking
of all your bonds.
I bite you injecting desire,
you are deliriously disturbed.
I swallow your head alive
for you to meet my throat.
I squeeze you down my neck to
your feet, licking them lazy.
You desperate inside me.
Death comes suddenly.
Those two translations were
made by Stacy Alba Hawkins.
Now, I'm going to read
the Spanish version.
Boa Constrictor.
Me balanceo de lado a
lado como un péndulo,
como el tic tac de
reloj, no sospechas nada.
Me miras de reojo, olfateas el aire
como tigre de bengala preparando el
gran zarpazo.
Esperas a que deje la piel en
algún rincón, soy tu presa,
uso mi cuerpo de carnada,
cantando mi siseo mortal.
Me muevo con piel nueva,
saco mi lengua lúdica,
te hipnotizo con mis ojos,
hasta dejarte quieto,
me abalanzo contra ti.
Enrollo tu cuerpo contra
el mío, ruges feroz,
te defiendes y ahogado
por mi abrazo,
escuchas cómo se rompen
todos tus huesos.
Te muerdo inoculando deseo de liras
turbado y me trago tu cabeza viva
para que conozcas mi garganta.
Te engullo por mi cuello hasta
los pies que relamo con pereza.
Te desesperas dentro de mí.
Aparece súbita la muerte.
Voy a leer la versión
en español del Arca.
Una boca que triza, una boca
que ulula, una boca que silva,
que gorjea, que ajea, que gañe,
que pía, que croa, que estrida,
que vozna, que bala, que zumba,
que zurea, que canta, que crotora,
que grazna, que grasita, que
barrita, que cacarea, que cloquea,
que clorofila, que resopla, que
rebrama, que chía, que relincha,
que estriba, que bufa, que ruge,
que ladra, que aúlla, que gime,
que impla, que maúlla, que
marramiza, que arrúa, que susurra,
que musita, que ronronea.
Una boca que habla, una boca
que ancla, una boca que grilla.
Si me das un beso yo puedo estribar
el mundo en el arca de tu boca.
We are going to the tree
in one towards the lake.
Second round about.
The translation of
Alba Skar-Hawkins.
A damn modern dream we were.
We owe the first seed to
captain Martín de Estete
and the first exploration
of San Juan
into the lakes Nicaraguan's
fresh water sea.
Behold the first war of
encouragements, for the richest
of the Indian and for the King of
Castilla nothing is impossible.
With this, we began our
discourse on scarcity.
Thus, arrived Henry Morgan, and
perhaps el Olonés [phonetic].
The British on the Atlantic Coast,
old providence indicated,
gracias a Dios.
How many times will the key to the
South Sea fall out of our hands?
The golden key held by Martin de la
Bastide, by Alexander Von Humboldt
and by William Walker
and our key to breath.
We were Napoleon's
canal, Napoleon's channel,
the new world Constantinople
with Squire [phonetic] we
were the route to gold.
We were the key of the Pacific
from the doctrina Monroe.
We were millions of channels
concession, millions of maps,
millions of routes, now in
the hands of a Chinese man.
A damn modern dream we were.
Where is my red flag?
Un maldito sueño moderno fuimos.
Le debemos la primera semilla
al capitán Martín Estete,
y la primera exploración al
desaguadero de la mar dulce.
He aquí la primera frase de aliento,
para la riqueza de las indias
y para un rey de Castilla,
poco es lo imposible, con ella
iniciamos nuestro discurso de
la escasez.
Así llegaron Henry
Morgan, y quizás el Olonés,
los británicos a la Costa Atlántica,
Isla Providencia y al
cabo, gracias a Dios.
¿Cuántas veces la llave de la mar
del sur se nos caería de las manos?
Aquella llave dorada de
Martín de la Bastide,
de Alejandro Humboldt y de William
Walker, y la llave nuestra del pan.
Fuimos el canal de Napoleón, la
Constantinopla del nuevo mundo,
fuimos con Squire tránsito
hacia el oro, fuimos the key
of the Pacific de la
doctrina Monroe.
Fuimos millones de
concesiones canaleras,
millones de mapas y
millones de rutas,
ahora en las manos de un chino.
Un maldito sueño moderno somos.
¿Dónde está mi bandera roja?
Llegamos a nuestro destino.
We reach our destination,
is the corner opposite
to the light house
stone, third round about.
The translation is from Alba
Skar-Hopkins, Latin Vulgate.
It is important to know
how to listen to words.
Those poor saint [phonetic]
that were once "the word".
Listen when they call me Latina,
when the entire north is Arizona.
Italian towns have not inherited the
name of the Latin King of Virgile.
"Oh, Latino who has stopped
being a Roman in order
to rescue the aboriginal"
We have all inherit the name
because we are the new world,
and at once, the original world.
Like a plumb serpent
that bites still.
But listen carefully when they
call me Latina in Arizona.
Listen to what is not
an empty sound.
Listen to how they call me
stone, how they call me dust.
Listen Tamagastad and Cipaltonal.
Listen when they call
me Latina in Arizona.
They just call me Eve.
Eve, the first rebel, from
the Latin, Latin Vulgate,
that the ship nailed to me.
Eve heroine transgressor, crossing
God's line and crossing man's border
to give birth to millions of esters.
But listen further, when they
call me Latina in Arizona,
how they are calling me agar.
Because God has no wanted
me to die in the desert,
and he has shown me a shortcut.
God has made a way out of no way.
Vulgata Latina.
Hay que saber escuchar
a las palabras,
esas pobres santas que
un día fueron verbo.
Escuchad cuando me llaman latina,
cuando todo el norte es Arizona.
No son los pueblos italianos los
herederos del nombre del rey latino
de Virgilio, ¡oh latino!
Que dejaste de ser romano
para rescatar al aborigen.
Somos los herederos del nombre
porque somos mundo nuevo y a la vez,
mundo de origen como serpiente
emplumada que se muerde la cola.
Más, escuchar con cuidado cuando
me llaman latina en Arizona.
Escuchad lo que no es sonido hueco.
Escuchad cómo me llaman
piedra, cómo me llaman polvo.
Escuchad Tamagastad y Cipaltonal.
Escuchad cuando me llaman latina en
Arizona, como también me llaman Eva.
Eva, la primera rebelde de la
Vulgata Latina que me clavaron
los barcos.
Eva, heroína transgresora cruzando
el límite de Dios y cruzando la
frontera del hombre para
procrear millones de seres.
Pero escuchad un poco más cuando
me llaman latina en Arizona,
cómo me están llamando agar porque
no ha querido Dios que perezca en el
desierto, y me ha mostrado un atajo.
God has made a way, out of no way.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Catalina.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov